well let's get reaction to that report's
findings general david petraeus the
former commander of the isaf the
international military mission in
afghanistan and former director of the
cia joins us now from arlington in
virginia general petraeus good to see
you this afternoon thank you for joining
us here on sky news
good to be with you sir jane thank you
um you'll have had a chance to have a
look at the findings of this report
published here in the uk about the uk's
withdrawal from afghanistan summed up as
a disaster and a betrayal from what you
witnessed unfold with that uh
withdrawal from afghanistan is that
something you would agree with
certainly i think i would um i'd
describe the withdrawal from afghanistan
as heartbreaking tragic uh and
disastrous
and i think this report captures that
obviously from british perspective and
with respect to what britain was doing
as part of an overall policy that really
was largely determined obviously by
the u.s decision and determination to
withdraw by two consecutive
administrations in washington
uh i found the report really quite in a
way characteristically british though
it's it's forthright uh it's factual
uh it is unsparing
uh and
you know kudos to tom tuckenhut who i
know and to the team and and of course
it's known that i was one of the
witnesses for this
effort if you were to apply those same
principles to the us's withdrawal from
afghanistan and be forthright about that
what would your
personal findings be about the united
states withdrawal from afghanistan at
that time
well again the bottom line is that the
ultimate
effect i think was disastrous it
condemned a country of some 40 million
citizens whom we sought to help for 20
years at considerable uh sacrifice both
in the part of coalition
members and also afghans in fact
mostly afghans keep in mind that these
accusations that the afghans wouldn't
fight were just unfounded there 26 or 27
times as many afghan soldiers were
killed
as were american soldiers for example
um i said when the decision was
announced that i feared that we would
come to regret this decision and i think
that we have
the decision and also the way withdrawal
was conducted also allowed potential
adversaries to
say that the u.s is not a dependable
partner and a great power in decline now
i don't believe in either of those
and i believe that the us and uk and by
the way the uk has been walking point in
many respects uh in the response to
the russian unprovoked invasion of
ukraine
but i believe that we are showing
together now together with the rest of
nato and the rest of the western world
that again
uh certainly the u.s can and does lead
the world uh when the interests are seen
and i
am hugely disappointed that we didn't
see that our interests should have led
us to maintain a very modest force
noting that the uk and just about all of
the other coalition members wanted to
stay
and of course were unable to influence
washington to do that
the decision was made
and you feel it it was the wrong one
however there was a lot of time for
nations to be prepared to evacuate from
afghanistan the uk of course being a big
part of that and i just want to pick up
on some of the key points in this report
key failures um they've called them but
one is about leadership something you
know a thing or two about it has to be
said
a top civil servant in the foreign
office sir philip barton was on holiday
at the time as was the uk foreign
secretary and the prime minister
none of them cut their leave short as
kabul fell now the report said this
marks a fundamental lack of seriousness
grip or leadership at a time of national
emergency are you shocked by the actions
of our leaders at a time when
afghanistan a country that the uk and
western allies have been invested in for
so long
didn't take the kind of urgent action
that now they are probably regretting
well i'm sure that they are and i'm sure
that they obviously misjudged what was
going to play out that
should not have been um actually a
surprise uh
i and a number of others a month or more
before the withdrawal
said that i fear that uh there could be
a psychological collapse of the afghan
security forces indeed there's a special
invest
inspector general report out just in the
united states which notes that
two administrations in the us completely
underestimate what the effect was of the
decision to withdraw when it was
announced
on the afghans both afghan military and
police and and afghans in government as
well there was just a complete lack of
appreciation
uh for what the impact of that was on
those who we were depending to continue
to fight uh and noting that of course
one of the really overlooked elements of
this was not just that we withdrew 3 500
u.s forces or less actually 8 500
coalition forces
we also withdrew over 15 000 contractors
western contractors who were needed
desperately to maintain the most
important element in the afghan military
which was the air component particularly
the helicopters
that are relied upon to bring the
reinforcements out to any one of the
afghan
elements around the country who are
under attack and these are quite good
forces about 3 500 commandos
comprise that reserve
and the key was the u.s blackhawk
helicopters that would ferry them out
there and also provide emergency
resupply air medivac and also then there
was close air support uh as another
element of that yeah
actually i'm quite cl pleased that
you've put that context to the situation
there because one of the excuses we kept
hearing after
the the fall of kabul is that the speed
of the takeover of the taliban couldn't
have been anticipated it took everyone
by surprise do you buy that as an excuse
no i i think it could have been and
should have been again
as i said i did state publicly and i was
a bit cautious with my words
and
was all along and again by the way i
don't do domestic politics so don't ask
me what should happen to the individuals
in the foreign office or something like
that i don't do that here either
but in terms of this policy
uh i think there was a complete lack of
appreciation for the effect on
all of these entities in afghanistan uh
frankly we now know that the taliban
once they knew that we were leaving
started to negotiate with those on the
front lines and once the front lines
realize nobody's coming to the rescue
why should they continue to fight
afghans are survivors they have seen
different countries forces wash across
them numerous times of course british
forces among them
on many
quite famous occasions
and in this case we just completely
missed that the other big error here was
conducting a withdrawal at the height of
the fighting season so the conditions
could not have been more propitious for
the taliban and the haqqani network and
the other elements of their particular
opposition force
uh to make the attacks and to then march
to kabul um so again there were just
enormous misjudgments and
miscalculations and again failure to
appreciate
uh the timing of this you know why not
do it in the middle of winter when at
least it's snowing and it's hard to get
to kabul
and you might have some chance by the
way there are a number of failings on
the afghan side as well the special
inspector general report for afghanistan
notes as an example that
then president ashraf ghani fired all of
his senior military in the final weeks
and replaced them with older ones that
he felt in whom he had more confidence
but basically from the communist era you
know that's an enormous blow to morale
in the ranks if you see all those who
have earned their way into these
positions over many years of very tough
fighting all of a sudden swept aside
because the president doesn't have con
confidence in them and also a failure to
craft a true
uh defensive concept for the country
which should have acknowledged that okay
we can't defend everything
but by golly we can defend these and
these will be our priority and this is
how we're going to do this and if
necessary you know the kind of zelinski
leadership that has been positively
churchillian in the case of uh ukraine
uh was completely lacking obviously in
kabul where all the intrigue and
scheming and all the rest of that had
been debilitating for many years
but was particularly so in this
particular situation general petraeus
i'm conscious we have limited time with
you and there is so much to talk about
when it comes to
afghanistan we can't possibly cover it
all but i do want to talk to you about
duty of care another key failure found
in this report
was that
afghan allies afghan nationals that
helped the west um during the war were
let down there was a shocking absence of
a plan to help them i mean you'll have
worked with many of them you'll have
looked in their eyes when you work with
them and you know i know many promises
were made to look after them because
they helped the western sadly for so
many we talk about the afghans being
survivors many of them sadly haven't
survived because they were left behind
by the west i just wanted to get your
reflection on that
well what you're describing is a moral
obligation uh and we have not met that
moral obligation uh certainly in the
united states nor in a number of other
countries that's that had forces there
in the u.s we have something called the
special immigrant visa which is extended
to
afghans who serve two or more years now
it's actually been shortened to a year i
believe by a recent change in the law
but again in other words they served on
the front lines as battlefield
interpreters sharing risk and hardship
with our soldiers in many cases they did
many years
on the ground alongside our small units
platoons our son was a platoon leader
there had his terp uh with him during
that period of time and that terp had
already served with several other units
prior to that and served with others
after that they were an enormous
hardship and risk and so forth
and we left
the state department believes that it
could be over a hundred thousand because
we guarantee their families the special
immigrant visa as well as the
individuals who earned it because of
course the
lives are at risk also um
those are still there this is a trickle
that we are getting out and again this
is a real failure uh on our part and i
think that a number of other countries
uh have done the same sadly that doesn't
count at all the hundreds of thousands
of other individuals who
incurred risk by just serving in the
afghan government working to achieve our
mutual goals and objectives
and of course members of their families
and and i'm sure that all of the
veterans there just as i do receive
numerous uh emails and messages through
various means on a daily basis from
those who have been left behind i
support no one left behind which is a
non-profit in the u.s which has enormous
legal expertise considerable financial
resources and so forth to help those
get here and then get their feet on the
ground once they are here
we just haven't been able to get enough
out actually to really do what we need
to do in that regard and so again we
have not met that obligation
to be fair
the president of afghanistan did not
want to alarm people not unlike by the
way president zielinski who right up
until the invasion started uh didn't
want uh certain actions taken either for
fear of alarming the public
um but that obviously was a big
miscalculation as well so their
calculations they've had so many
consequences general david petraeus i'm
conscious that you have to go so i just
want one final question to you if i may
a closing thought if you look at
afghanistan now and the rapid decline
since that final evacuation we're
looking at a country an economic crisis
in the midst of a famine 95 of the
population in afghanistan
going hungry in some respect
is there any future for the west
in afghanistan can they ever work with
the taliban what is the future for
afghanistan because this is a country
that has gone back to the dark ages
since the the west of withdrawal
well i think you've characterized that
very well sarah jane it is the dark ages
it's an 8th or 9th century
interpretation of islam that is beyond
ultra-conservative now
women of course even have to cover even
their faces they're very restricted in
what they can do outside the home in the
economy and so forth so 50 of the
population
is severely restricted girls can't go to
high school much less to college as they
used to be able to do
uh all of this uh not to mention a
variety of other uh of the governmental
policies that
are not going to bring the economy back
needless to say it has collapsed
and i see no prospect of anyone from the
outside be willing being willing to
invest much in fact the
biggest economy biggest elements of the
economy now tragically are those that
surround illegal narcotics
there's a big meth problem there now in
addition to of course the problem
they've always had with with poppy and
opium related uh illegal narcotics so it
is an absolutely tragic situation i do
know that diplomats do and others the
policymakers here are seriously and and
truly concerned about that trying to
figure out how to provide assistance to
those who are most in need through
non-government organizations that could
avoid strengthening the taliban in the
regime and so forth and rewarding them
for their very very again
ultra-conservative actions
but it is an absolute tragedy again and
this is why as i said uh the outcome
there uh has been heartbreaking it has
been tragic and i believe it has been
disastrous
general david petraeus we thank you so
much for your time here on sky news so
good to get your insight and your
reaction to that report on the uk's
withdrawal published today thank you
thank you